what if the latest when it comes to the
covert 19 mortality crisis in the UK
well let's have a look at the data that
we've just had through this shows you
this line shows you the average number
of deaths in each week of the year for
the last five years and this is across
the whole of the UK let's have a look at
2020 you can see the pandemic striking
there a very big number of what they
call excess deaths so anything above
that line is what's called excess deaths
then it came down the number of excess
deaths but then it started to rise just
in that latest week for which we have
data now that is primarily because of
registrations it's not necessarily an
uptick in the severity of the dudes
disease or in deaths it's because
registrations just will lower that week
than they should have been and higher
that week because they were catching up
so be reassured that we're not
necessarily seeing a rise in deaths
there but certainly that line there the
black line is well above the average and
when you tot up all the number of people
who have sadly died both of this disease
and other causes it is getting to a
terrifying level so covert 19 deaths
since March again for the whole of the
UK we're talking about around 45,000 add
on other excess deaths that haven't
necessarily got an explanation above
that line and you're talking about an
extra 14,000 and then the deaths that
we've had in the period since May the
15th because most that data's from May
is around three to seven thousand that's
according to the Institute of faculty of
actuaries and that would employ 64,000
excess deaths so far as a result of this
pandemic the number far higher than
anyone would have liked to have seen and
much of that is because of where it's
happened so these show you excess deaths
the lines anything above the line is an
excess death here at home hospitals and
particularly care homes you can see the
epicenter of this crisis just showing
you how far those lines are above zero
is in care homes even now you're seeing
lots of excess deaths in care homes in
these latest data and part of the
consequence of that is the UK does have
one of the worst mortality crises in the
world in fact now the UK in population
adjusted terms Coe bid 19 deaths per
million has now overtaken Italy and only
Belgium and Spain have bigger outbreaks
in terms of deaths
million of the population you can see
actually Sweden a little way down there
island in the US there but the UK
unfortunately rising in that league
table